did you know that it's actually against
the law for Ron DeSantis to run for
president unless he resigns his
governorship there is a Florida law that
forces Governors to resign if they want
to run for president of the United
States so what is Ron DeSantis going to
do well it's looking like Republicans in
Florida are looking at changing that law
specifically so that Ron DeSantis could
remain Governor while running now you
might say but David I remember that Jeb
Bush remember the please clap guy we're
prepared to act in the National Security
interests of this country to get back in
the business of creating a more peaceful
world
police clap Jeb Bush was governor and he
ran for president that's true but Jeb
Bush was not Governor at the time that
he was running for president he had
previously been a governor